ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir sans merci d'être là avec nous
ce soir un exécutif à la peine avec un
déplacement dijonnais du chef de l'état
qui ne semble pas avoir tenu toutes ses
promesses une majorité qui donne
toujours l'impression de douter une
opposition qui se réveille
bref les temps sont durs à un monsieur
le ministre et pas seulement pour les
français les questions sont multiples
évidemment ce soir suzette bloch de l'
agence france-presse
notre partenaire et puis perrine
tarneaud 2 public sénat nous rejoindront
pour ce preuve par 3 réalisé également
avec dailymotion qui permet aux
téléspectateurs de vous interpeller et
de réagir alors comme si les galères
diverses n'était pas assez pesant
offensive surprise de la neige paralyse
donc une partie du pays
c'est vrai chaos d'ailleurs dans
certains coins de france aujourd'hui
et déjà certains naufragés dénoncent un
manque d'anticipation que répondez vous
vous savez d'abord il ya une situation
qui est grave le gouvernement a réagi
immédiatement le premier ministre a
activé la cellule de crise et je pense
que c'est aussi ces circonstances qui
rappelle à quoi servent les les services
publics on parlera tout à l'heure du
budget de l'état mais vous voyez il faut
aussi des gens pour déneiger les routes
il faut des gens pour protéger les
français de nous verser là pour le faire
fonctionner je ne sais pas je crois que
chaque inscrit non parce que il faut pas
être avoir l'assurance que tout est
parfait on a fait tout ce qui était en
situation de faire avec les moyens dont
nous disposons le premier ministre
dirige la réponse qui est apportée à
cette situation là mais je crois qu'à
chaque fois on s'améliore et je préfère
lier à un certain nombre de critiques un
peu extravagante que j'attends du côté
de l'opposition
par secteurs inondés mois insulté et
demandé aux missions dans kate
le mieux c'est que je fasse répondent
quelqu'un de l'opposition à quelqu'un de
l'opposition car monsieur bussereau cet
après-midi dit que lui il a été ministre
des transports et je le cite qu'il a été
confronté aux mêmes événements et que la
proposition d'une commission denquête
dont je crois que madame pécresse tout à
fait extravagant et je crois que je
crois qu'il dira je crois qu il dit
juste le gouvernement est présent on a
réagi il ya eu deux réunions aujourd'hui
la commission ad-hoc pour répondre à
cette situation là et effectivement le
gouvernement est très présent et
partagent des difficultés des français
était de mobiliser encore plus de moyens
alors nous parlons à l'heure où nous
parlons tous les moyens sont mobilisés
et y compris il a été envisagé par le
gouvernement de surveiller pratiquement
à la minute près la cellule de crise et
ce à la situation des français de chaque
français lé préfet les services publics
dans les départements sont mobilisés
alors le chef de l'état à dijon bahadur
évoqué la situation cet épisode neigeux
ce retour en force de la neige il a dit
qu'il fallait des dispositifs
exceptionnels face à des circonstances
exceptionnelles
on va reparler quand même de l'objectif
politique 1 de son déplacement chez son
ami françois rebsamen
est-ce qu'il a raté ce déplacement à
dijon selon vous le chef de l'état pour
reconquérir le coeur des français c'est
un petit peu l'impression qui se dégage
est ce que vous la partagez
je ne sais pas de hudur on tire ce
commentaire savez quand le président de
la république va à dijon il décide
d'aller il le dit lui-même à l'écouté
des français ça veut dire que les tarifs
français au contact à l'écouté des
français que les français puissent
s'exprimer qu'ils puissent avoir un
contact direct avec lui il faut choisir
on peut pas lui reprocher de ne pas
s'exprimer ou de rester enfermé à
l'elysée et quand tu y vas sur le
terrain de le lui reprocher aussi après
il y a eu deux ou trois images dont
certains raffole trop d'erreurs il ya eu
des faits un syndicaliste qui est de sud
qui vient et qui dit vous tenez pas vos
points s'il a droit de le dire ça droit
de son sentiment c'est pas vraiment une
surprise du point de merdes ma question
est celle-ci est ce que vous allez
demander une enquête pour essayer de
comprendre la brutalité des policiers
qui ont expulsé manu militari sec les
opposants qui ont d ailleurs les
promesses elles sont est-ce que
l'important c'était la discussion le
discours du président de la réponse
réponse à l'inquiétude des français où
cet événement avec quelqu'un qui est là
au milieu qui crie ces images qui
parlent des brutalités policières
brutalité policière on va demander
effectivement de que se soit apaisée
enfin c'est quelqu'un qui est pris est
qui et qui est sortie c'était des
policiers locaux d'après ce que je sais
mais c'est vers une maladresse
une maladresse c'est possible manuel
valls le fasse savoir également à ses
troupes de son côté ou à écouter je
pense franchement je crois qu'il ya eu
des incidents plus graves et que je suis
assez étonné assez étonné qu'on fasse
une montagne de cet événement là par
rapport à ce qui était latente des
français l'objet peut critiquer le
discours mais bon voilà c'est l'herbe et
l'acte de communication avec notamment à
internet
il faut en tenir compte tout prend une
ampleur ces gens tiennent compte mais
c'est pas parce qu'on n'en tienne compte
qu'il ne faut pas apporter une nuance à
la hiérarchie des fainéants mois après
cette expérience que c'est ce que ce
type de déplacement prolongé donc avec
une nuit sur place sera renouvelée on
avait dit à l'elysée peut-être une fois
toutes les six semaines
écoutez j'espère vous espérez j'espère
parce que il faut pas que ces incidents
la et dans tous les cas je dirais
l'extrapolation qui en est faite
aujourd'hui et les commentaires que je
vois ici ou là décourage le président de
la république je crois que le président
de la république françois hollande
il a une image il a une personnalité
propre qui est celle justement de
quelqu'un qui est proche des français
qui ne va manquer la réception des
sondages la mi temps mais on va parler
qui ne va pas dans un univers ultra
protégée inaccessible dans lequel il
aurait personne cet événement la montre
lui-même d'ailleurs qu' il ya eu
effectivement il est cet homme qui était
contre il pouvait être la preuve lors il
s'est exprimé on va parler du discours
de fond en ce qu'il a affirmé des choses
fortes houles une orientation une
volonté en tous les cas mais d'abord sur
la popularité est ce que vous estimez
que françois hollande est condamné à
l'impopularité désormais durant tout son
quinquennat
pas du tout pas du tout je pense que
l'impopularité d'aujourd'hui elle
s'explique là aussi je crois qu'il faut
regarder les chiffres
avec attention notamment le dernier
sondage de ipsos le point sur lequel on
focalise le moins cinq points d'un coup
d'un seul oui mais est-ce que vous avez
regardé la page de derrière il porte sur
l'ensemble des personnalités politiques
et ça permet aussi de regarder les
choses tous les neuf ça ne profite pas
la droite ça profite pas et il ya ça
c'est une leçon politique qu'on doit
prendre en compte c'est à dire une
suspicion ou plutôt une suspicion
d'absence d'efficacité vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble de la de la pollution ça
c'est une vraie question est sage et ça
ça et ça c'est quelque chose qui n'est
qui nous interpelle mais je crois que
quand on regarde c'est plutôt ça la
leçon de ce sont alors quand vous
entendez dire que par exemple nicolas
sarkozy se posant en recours pour 2010
est on cas justement où on pourrait
redouter dans notre pays une déferlante
populiste c'est à dire front national
vous comprenez son attitude et je trouve
que sa méthode d'abord lé pas d'une
franchise totale faire une interview
donné une interview sans avoir l'air de
la donner tout en la donnant à travers
des propos rapportés qui ne sont pas
démentis je pense que le je préfère un
discours qui est froid on dirait que
celui que tient le président de la
république et le premier ministre
aujourd'hui encore d'accord mais sur la
vanité de retour sur le fond nicolas
sarkozy ont dit qu'ils hésitent entre le
retour en politique et puis
éventuellement la direction d'un fonds
souverain du qatar vous lui dites mais
je pense ans et vous dans les affaires
c'est son problème premièrement et
deuxièmement je pense pas que ce soit un
message pour la france je pense pas que
ce soit un message pour les français
c'est un message pour l'ump pour ses
concurrents c'est à dire que ce bertrand
fillon et copé qui se sentent des ailes
et qui commence à se mettre un pied
d'égalité avec nuit leur dis halte là de
jouer vous êtes en seconde division
moi je reste en première division mais à
droite alors vous dites que françois
hollande pourra rebondir dans les
sondages
d'ici la fin de son quinquennat on se
souvient que françois mitterrand et
jacques chirac avait pu rebondir eux
mais dans une seule circonstance la
cohabitation
certains évoquent des élections
législatives anticipées et la politique
fiction n'est pas n'est pas interdite
mais ça n'a aucune réalité
dans quelles conditions les français
pourrait retrouver le chemin de la
confiance alors qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
sur une défiance mais kate une défiance
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble du personnel
politique nous sommes dans une situation
de crise nous sommes dans une situation
difficile et nous tenons un langage de
vérité mais qui n'est pas un langage de
soumission c'est ça c'est ça
nous ne sommes pas là simplement de dire
ben pour l'instant ça va mal il ya qu à
attendre donc nous attendons pas ce que
nous avons fait en 10 mois alors on nous
reproche de ne pas avoir en dix mois les
résultats à d'avoir réussi à réparer ce
que les autres ont détruit en dix ans
mais depuis ce que les français pourrait
me reprocher c'est de ne rien faire
ça c'est un ami non non ne faisons que
ça chaque jour nous mettons en place des
dispositifs dont certains ne sont même
pas entré à la rade application le
travail notamment sur la flexibilité la
compétitive alors j'y suis presque sûr
la compétitive surtout on va en parler
le texte je parle de la compétitivité
pour les entreprises et les 20 milliards
que nous avons des grandes heures des
premiers chocs
le premier chèque a été signée par
pierre moscovici lundi
trois cent cinquante mille euros pour
une entreprise de 450 salariés dans le
puy de dôme
ça c'est très concret 4% de la masse
salariale mise à disposition un modèle
pourrait être gerhard schröder qui lui
décidez de réformes radicales en
allemagne il a remis son pays sur de
bons rails économique mais il en a
sacrifié son destin politique
oui je pense que c'est pas du tout notre
modèle est qu'il faut avoir
il faut porter un regard très lucide sur
ce qui a été fait en allemagne et la
comparaison en l'occurrence n'est pas
raison les résultats d'abord la
politique elle même
notre projet c'est pas de généraliser
les petits boulots à 400 euros c'est
même exactement l'inversé de ce qu'on
fait dans l'accord sur la sécurisation
de l'emploi donc le modèle n'est pas
celui des gerard schröder et en même
temps les résultats de l'allemagne
aujourd'hui ça mériterait d'être regardé
vous savez la démographie sur le plan
industriel
oui mais la situation l'exportation
surtout l'exportation c'est ça le
résultat tant la performance
industrielle via un lien via un lien
entre les deux débats savez pourquoi
l'allemagne qui a eu une croissance
faible à un moment donné pourquoi ils
n'ont pas licencié parce qu'ils avaient
une autre méthode pour gérer la ce qu'on
appelle la flexibilité interne et ça
c'est très important de ce point de vue
là l'accord qui a été passé en france
il s'inspire un peu de ce constat qu'est
terrible intérieur dix fois plus de
chômage partiel en allemagne qu'en
france à dire que les entreprises
allemagne dans la difficulté
non pas licencier les gens ou du chômage
partiel ils ont eu de la formation et
dès qu'il ya une petite reprise
ils ont cette compétence qui sont qui
sont là pour parler du fond quand même
un de ce discours de françois hollande à
dijon est ce que vous êtes satisfait de
l'entendre assumer de plus en plus son
positionnement sur une orientation
sociale démocrate quand il s'attaque à
tous les blocages de la société nous
sommes social démocrate c'est
l'engagement c'est l'alternative qui
existent en france parfois difficile a
avoué face aux réticences à gauche
même au ps non mais nous sommes social
démocrate se dire personne au parti
socialiste aujourd'hui c'est pas notre
projet de société nous sommes pas pour
une économie administrée
nous sommes pour une économie qui a
besoin d'entreprises et nous sommes pour
un équilibre dans la situation qui
existe aujourd'hui et notamment que les
salariés du pouvoir dans l'entreprise
c'est aussi le contenu de l'accord et
que la croissance qui est absolument
nécessaire on peut faire toutes les
réformes qu'on veut il nous faut de la
croissance est aujourd'hui un objectif
partagé
vous êtes c'est clair l'exécutif pour un
socialisme de l'offre pour l'innovation
pour la compétitivité des entreprises
il ya trois objectifs le redressement
des finances publiques
d'accord mais j'parle la compétitivité
des entreprises innovation est la
priorité à l'emploi et c'est pas l'une
après l'autre ces trois objectifs se
conjugue en même temps c'est ça la
logique et la cohérence voudrait donc le
socialisme de l'offre ça vous va la
social-démocratie saisir je veux pas le
socialisme de l'offre comme étant un
objectif à n'est pas appuyé ce que ça ne
veut rien dire ça ça veut dire c'est une
partie de la réponse mais il ne faut pas
opposer le socialisme de l'offre à l'eau
au socialisme de la distribution c'est
un tout nous sommes des sociaux
démocrates et nous conjuguons l'ensemble
de ses objectifs en même temps mais vous
pensez vraiment que viendra le temps de
la redistribution au cours de ce
quinquennat comme l'avait promis au bout
de deux ans hollande c'est une question
de 2 de croissance
patience je pensais que vous ne vient
pas des patiences justement et vous avez
raison de réagir comme ça parce que ce
qu'on pourrait nous reprocher c'est de
dire c'est une question de patience
on n'est pas là comme sera n'attendre
que la croissance revienne nous mettons
en place les outils de la banque
publique d'investissement ce dont je
vous ai parlé sur le crédit
compétitivité sont ce sont des mesures
qui sont prises aujourd'hui et qui entre
en application sur question je parle
encore de genre collomb il dit il faut
abandonner l'idée de 75% de taxation sur
les très hauts revenus vous êtes
d'accord
non je suis pas d'accord c'est rien
objectif c'est un objectif qui reste on
attend l'avis du conseil d'état et
jérôme cahuzac a précisé que de toute
façon se dit le dispositif alternatif
puisqu'il faut qu'on en trouve une autre
sera dans la loi de finances pour 2014
l'ump a déposé sa première motion de
censure elle sera débattue le 20 mars
bon c'est un exercice classique vous
avez beaucoup fait ça lorsque vous étiez
dans l'opposition sur ce mal
l'opposition a des droits et c'est un c3
qu'elle exerce naturellement le débat
politique a lieu au parlement et c'est
tout à fait logique et nous allons y
répondre
le premier parc aux arguments tout à
fait bien certains doutent du premier
ministre mais certains doutent du
premier ministre qui lui est ravi d'être
à dijon par exemple s'adresser aux
entreprises
non mais le président de la république
ne peut pas rester lui tout seul à
l'elysée i die sur le terrain le premier
ministre le fait tous les jours le
premier ministre il dirige le
gouvernement
et je peux vous dire que jean marc
ayrault ne ménage pas sa peine ni
solvant et donc il est à sa place
une coordonner l'action de l'action du
gouvernement il est dans une relation de
confiance c'est très important
total avec le président de la république
va pas changer ça c'est extrêmement bas
change ça n'a pas changé
ça c'est une garantie pour l'efficacité
de l'exécutif en va voir quelles sont
vos difficultés avec votre majorité avec
l'opposition vous entendu elle semble
même s'intensifier déjà certains
parlementaires disent oui on va
surveiller de très près les choix
courageux qu'annonce françois hollande
en matière de retraite on va en parler
avec suzette bloch qui est avec nous on
parle pas non plus des parlementaires du
front de gauche qui eux ne vont par
exemple pas voter la loi sur la
refondation de l'école on voit ça avec
suzette dans un instant mais d'abord le
point donc sur les socialistes un qui
vous donne du fil à retordre à monsieur
le ministre
mathilde et bélanger expliqué le cap
faire de la pédagogie sur l'action
gouvernementale c'était l'objectif de
ces deux jours à dijon et pour beaucoup
au sein même de la majorité
il était temps les parlementaires
socialistes sont nombreux à demander
plus de clarté à 3 soit au lond pour
certains le chef de l'état a péché par
excès d'optimisme
il aurait fallu dire plutôt la gravité
de la situation économique
je crois que chacun a le sentiment qu'on
a peut-être manqué l'occasion l'an passé
de dire les choses de manière claire et
nex et que cette occasion repassera pas
plusieurs fois il faut le faire
maintenant après il sera trop tard
les parlementaires s'inquiètent aussi de
la cacophonie au sein du gouvernement
dernier en date la question de la
fiscalisation du diesel a vu s'opposer
publiquement à arnaud montebourg
delphine batho et cécile duflot un
manque de cohérence pointé du doigt par
le chef des sénateurs socialistes
françois rebsamen et par certains
députés y a pas besoin d'un recadrage en
soit il ya besoin que les certains
ministres soir car et qu'ils arrivent à
comprendre qu'ils ne sont plus des
militants socialistes qui dans la salle
des quatre colonnes peuvent faire les
déclarations qu'il souhaite mais qu'ils
sont dépositaires de l'intérêt général
et donc ils doivent calibré dans
interventions en fonction c'est un cas
mais les parlementaires sont aussi
sévères vis-à-vis du parti socialiste
qui ne tiendrait pas son rôle
d'animateur du débat politique
car les interrogations portent aussi sur
le fond le choix de la rigueur et de
plus en plus contestée en particulier à
la gauche du parti
c'est un mauvais choix parce que
j'entends des formules du genre un
effort va être demandé à tous les
français il ya des gens qui ne peuvent
plus faire d'efforts il ya des gens qui
sont en dessous du niveau de flottaison
je pense que ce qui manque aujourd'hui
c'est un équilibre entre les efforts et
les retours sur ses efforts et que
françois hollande aurait d'une certaine
manière le gouvernement peut être
intérêt à accélérer certaines réformes
je pense à la réforme fiscale
après dijon françois hollande se livrera
un nouvel exercice de pédagogie
il devrait s'exprimer à la télévision
avant la fin du mois en question à la
vie d'alice bonsoir monsieur le ministre
harlem désir des fonds tout ce qui ne se
fera pas la taxe à 75% la pema le non
cumul des mandats dès 2014 y at il un
problème au ps
est-ce que je peux reprendre votre liste
la taxe à 75%
je le répète il ya une annulation par le
conseil constitutionnel nous avons saisi
le conseil d'état et jérôme cahuzac a
confirmé qu'il y aurait une réponse dans
la loi de finances pour 2004 mais non
puisque je viens de vous dire oui on
attend la réponse du conseil d'état sur
ce qu'on peut faire ou pas faire la pma
sur la pma vous savez ce qui s'est passé
donc nous avons nous sommes dans la
tente la réponse du conseil national
d'éthique et lorsque le conseil national
d'éthique donnera sa position
aujourd'hui
le gouvernement n'a pas dit que
nous avions renoncé qu'il y aura une loi
sur la famille dans laquelle la question
pourra être traitée mais c'est tous les
cinq ans si le clé c'était une espèce de
boule être au gouvernement si j'ai bien
compris le ps et est aujourd'hui
l'expression de la majorité il
accompagne le gouvernement ah bon ça
vous trouvez qu'il accompagne mais
naturellement naturellement un
argumentaire l'a entendu gaëtan gorce
qui dit que le ps est complètement à
contre courant mais étant d un jean
christophe cambadélis attendait
l'expression de telle ou telle personne
ce parti n'est pas connu pour être un
parti monolithique
ce parti est quelque chose de vivant
dans laquelle beaucoup de gens
s'expriment la direction du parti
socialiste n'est pas aujourd'hui dans
une situation je ne sais quel conflit
elle est dans une situation
d'accompagnement de la politique en même
temps le parti en tant que tel garde son
autonomie et c'est normal qu'il y ait un
débat ou qu'ils aient les discussions
mais je préfère vous dire que c'est une
vision très réductrice de la qualité
d'élève de nos relations n'ont même le
patron des sénateurs ps françois
rebsamen qui hausse le ton
il dit il faut arrêter le concours
lépine des propositions fiscales et les
couvre semble plus voir chez vous d'un
peu partout maintenant lorsque françois
rebsamen dit cela et il a raison mais il
vit ce qui fait un ministre parfois
certains ministres et puis j'ai envie de
vous dire beaucoup beaucoup d'échos de
presse c'est assez extraordinaire de
voir que lorsque il ya un rapport qui
est demandé ici ou là avec des
propositions on a pendant trois jours
des articles partout où ils vont
fiscaliser les allocations familiales
personne jamais décidé ça mais le
gouvernement est obligé de dire non rien
rien n'est arrêté alors je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup d'impatience et que l'actualité
et des poudres de plus en plus rapide
mais aussi il ya aussi beaucoup de
petites phrases ministre c'est le point
oui des petites phrases mais qui sont
souvent sur des sujets qui n'ont pas été
arbitré et qui sont dans leur domaine de
compétence mais il n'y a qu'une seule
réponse politique et la réponse du
gouvernement
mais est ce que est ce que vous pensez
que
c'était l'intérêt de françois hollande
d'aller à dijon alors que les sénateurs
maires la veille et le matin même à
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé après ce coup
tiré dans les genoux on a dû quand même
du mal à comprendre parce que vous avez
vous est marquée par cinq années sarkozy
mais ça a été très conforme savez c'est
des choses sont organisées
on ne voit que des policiers il n'y a
aucune contestation c'est cadré question
sur les critiques
écoutez il est que françois hollande que
françois hollande est à dijon
chez françois rebsamen qui est quelqu'un
qui est important dans les institutions
de la république puisqu'il est président
du groupe oc et du sachant qu'il ya des
sujets sur lesquels ils sont pas
exactement d'accord mais franchement
c'est la nature même de ce parti aussi
de travailler ensemble depuis des années
pour élaborer dans la discussion de nous
sommes nous sommes nous avons des
rapports qui s'inspire de delà de la
démocratie et sur l'essentiel et sur la
politique à mener
ils sont absolument d'accord oui mais
alors là cet après midi l'autre barons
du ps ces thèmes sur mer 2 de lyon
gérard collomb tire aussi la sonnette
d'alarmé en disant en appelant lé en
avoir un langage clair je pense qu'il a
eu la réponse
en quoi en quoi le discours en quoi le
discours de françois hollande
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas un discours
clair les choses sont très précises
le président ben ali le président la
république aujourd'hui ben il a répondu
par un discours très clair à la tante de
gérard colomb et donc je dois je pense
qu'il doit être comblé sauf sur un point
c'est vrai lorsque gérard collomb dit il
faut uniquement faire une politique de
l'offre c'est parce que répond le
président de la république ya la
politique de l'offre et gérard collomb a
raison sur ce point mais en même temps
il ya la question de la réduction de
l'emploi avec des mesures qui ne sont
pas de la politique de l'offre quand on
fait les emplois d'avenir quand on fait
le contrat de génération et donc il faut
c'est pas l'un ou l'autre il ya une
cohérence de la politique que le
président de la république a rappelé cet
après midi autour de trois axes dont on
ne sortira pas et qui vont redresser la
france dans la justice qui sont le
désendettement qui sont la compétitivité
et qui sont la priorité à l'emploi
dans son discours françois lent à dijon
a expliqué qu'il fallait des choix
courageux sur les retraites et dans la
pratiquement la minute d'après un député
ps jérôme guedj dit nous serons
extrêmement attentifs parce que les
ménages ne pourront pas il faut pas
mettre en difficulté la consommation des
ménages
dans la minute près donc vous l'ignorez
pas vous connaissez vous savez qui est
jérôme guedj
ils expriment une sensibilité il
continue à l'exprimer il n'est pas
toujours d'accord avec la ligne et ça
fait aussi la richesse du 2 du parti du
parti socialiste mais sur la question de
la déclaration sur les retraites ce qui
est intéressant c'est de regarder très
précisément ce que dit le président de
la république et notamment sur en moquez
très important quand il dit on va faire
une réforme courageuse en tenant compte
de voix des 20 milliards annoncés de
déficit à l'horizon 2020 et surtout il
dit et de la pénibilité
eh bien je vais vous dire qu'elle est
aujourd'hui ce qui a de plus
inadmissibles sur l'airé sur la question
des retraites
eh bien c'est la question de l'espérance
de vie parce que quand vous êtes
aujourd'hui ouvriers que vous avez
travaillé dans un certain nombre de
circonstances travail de nuit travail
aux intempéries on sait tous on sait
tous que vous avez une espérance de vie
qui est réduite de 7 ans ou huit ans par
rapport à d'autres milieux il y avait
des mesures non pour ceux qui avaient
cotisé longtemps faut pas confondre des
deux choix être les bus sur sur
l'ajustement justement c'est s est
ouvert aux partenaires sociaux
je mets le fait que je ne vais pas vous
donner les réponses que donne une piste
ne les prenez pas pour argent comptant
mais c'est vrai que la majoration par
exemple de dire cinq années pour
recompter plus six ou sept années parce
que justement il ya cette question de
l'espérance de vie mais je vais vous
dire moi en tant que socialiste depuis
toujours je pense qu'il ya là une mesure
par rapport à l'ua l'une est scandaleux
finalement de la situation des retraites
une injustice fondamentale des gens qui
finalement qu'otis toute leur vie et qui
en profitent moins longtemps et bien si
on rentre dans la réforme les français
comprendront
mais si c'est que c'est une réforme et
ça c'est un des volets parce que
françois hollande parle de choix
courageux il marisol
voilà il marisol touraine ajoie tous les
français sont concernés
bien sûr que tous les français seront
concernés tous les ans aux seuls qui ont
eu des emplois pénibles vous nous avez
dès qu'ils auront droit à une espèce de
bonus en terme de l'île détient encore
là quand le président il faut pas
simplement voir le volet effort
supplémentaire pour trouver les 20
milliards si on a une réforme ce que
j'espère qui sera proposé puisqu'il ya
un comité d'experts qui va donner sans
rapports puis les partenaires sociaux le
président de la république à la halle a
rappelé puis des décisions ça veut dire
que ces décisions elles vont conjuguer
un impératif comment trouver 20
milliards
et là on va laisser la priorité rien
n'est arbitré à ce jour par enfant
s'oriente vers une agent un allongement
de la durée de cotisation mais vous ne
savez pas chef de l'état françois
hollande en a parlé plusieurs fois
pendant sa campagne il vous mais vous ne
savez pas aujourd'hui quelle sera la
solution s'il y aura plusieurs plusieurs
paramètres parmi les sur plusieurs
leviers que vous pouvez utiliser mais si
en même temps danse intégrée réforme il
y à la prise en compte de la question de
la pénibilité alors je crois que les
français comprendront le sens c'est très
fort alors vous êtes au centre du
dispositif chargé de faire l'interface
entre le parlement et les ministres
alors pourquoi pourquoi cette
incohérence au niveau des ministres
c'est l'inexpérience et un problème de
direction
expliquez-nous un peu esseulé
parlons sur des faits précis où vous
pensez à quoi il ya plein de divergences
qu'ils sont exprimés sur la fiscalité du
diesel par exemple sur leurs maillots
sion des amendes de contraventions et
même sur l'effort de rigueur puisque ses
gestes il ya des ministres delphine
batho cécile duflot qui disent voilà il
faut pas nous étrangler on va pas
pouvoir gérer nos ministères ne pourra
plus écoutée s'est passé pas une
incohérence il ya une ligne politique et
il ya des efforts chacun avait dit que
françois rebsamen avez raison de parler
d' incohérences n'en faisais pas je vous
avais pas dit ça c'est vous qui faites
le commentaire je vous ai repris pour
vous dire que françois rebsamen avait
raison par rapport à la nécessité de
soutenir l'action du président de la
république mais qu'il rappelle à la
nécessité de faire bloc je le peux je le
partage complètement mais je ne souscris
pas à ce que vous venez de dire je ne
crois pas aujourd'hui franchement que la
marque de fabrique de ce gouvernement
ce soit des difficultés à l'intérieur
des ministres enfin vous êtes
suffisamment observateurs pour voir que
quand on dit on va faire des efforts
qu'il y ait quelques mille dix qui
disent bon moi je d'efforts mais c'est
normal il y fit il en l'europe mais
quand l'arbitrage est revenu c'est pas
la situation à l'encontre d'un quart
étaient fixés sur les nouvelles est en
crue jetair aucun ministre aucun des
mini 110 l'horizon les exigences ne sont
pas bonnes que ya des ministres qui
pensent que leur secteur
ça montre plutôt un investissement de la
part mais le jour jérôme cahuzac l'a dit
très clairement il ya de leur dit
clairement
sauf que sauf que faut quand même
rappeler et jérôme cahuzac a rappelé que
les priorités du président de la
république seront respectés la jeunesse
l'éducation l'emploi la police et la
gendarmerie question est ce que vous
êtes que manuel valls sceptique sur la
proposition de loi communiste sur
l'aministie sociale votée au plan au
sénat
la soutenez vous comme christiane
taubira la position du gouvernement
c'est pas un soutien je pense pas que
vous puissiez dire que saint-omer a
soutenu le gouvernement
le gouvernement a dit sagesse
ces avancées mais le revers ma position
la position du gouvernement ça a été de
dire sagesse c'est à dire de laisser le
sénat délibéré puisque c'est une
initiative parlementaire c'est une
proposition de loi du mazel trop loin
liste à l'origine oui alors évident vous
noté liste à l'origine oui les choses
doivent être claires tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est atteinte à la personne
tout ce qui est non respect des
fonctionnaires qui sont chargés de
l'autorité publique
tout cela il n'est évidemment pas
question que ça puisse faire l'objet de
madame cissé
ça a été la démarche du groupe
socialiste aujourd'hui nous avons avec
nous verrons bien ce qu'on pense
assemblée nationale parce qu'il faut
aussi respecter respecter ce débat merci
beaucoup sujets peuvent être avec nous
ce soir
perrine tarneaud de public sénat va nous
rejoindre maintenant monsieur vide à dix
on va parler de textes importants dont
on va examiner la porter dans les heures
qui viennent
on voit ça donc tout de suite après
cette première évocation d'un autre vote
qui va intervenir début avril cette fois
au sénat avec des débats sans doute
moins en fait mais qu'il ya quelques
semaines il s'agit du mariage gay paul
bouffard on ne prévoit ni nuit blanche
ni débat enflammé les discussions du
projet de loi sur le mariage homosexuel
devrait être moins houleux ce qu'à
l'assemblée nationale pourtant le vote
ne sera pas simple certains sénateurs
plaidé pour un vote conforme
un vote sans modification du texte ce
qui éviterait un retour devant les
députés
mais pour le père du pacs jean-pierre
michel rapporteur du texte
il faut encore régler un certain nombre
d'imperfections le texte je le prendre
tel qu'il est c'est à dire que je
n'ajoute rien c'est le mariage ouvert
aux couples de même sexe et l'adoption
voilà c'est tout est donc dans ce cadre
là que tu apportes à faire lors de
modifications juridiques mais qui sont
vraiment très très technique
le rapporteur socialiste prévoit une
dizaine d'amendements mais rien sur les
questions de pma et gpa
en revanche certaines composantes de la
gauche sénatoriale risque bien
d'alimenter le débat comme le groupe
écologiste à l'assemblée
c'est plus de cinq mille amendements qui
ont été déposés
parole du l'ump au sénat il n'y aura ni
entrave ni excès le vote de l'opposition
sera plus raisonnable
je pense que la méthode de travail va
différents d'abord nous n'allons pas
utiliser la voie des milliers
d'amendements qui a été utilisé à
l'assemblée nationale je pense qu'au
contraire on va se focaliser sur
quelques centaines d'amendements
d'autres ont tout de même envie de
débattre pour défendre leurs convictions
personnelles ni né à droite ni à gauche
on devrait vraiment se sentir
complètement libre c'est non seulement
une tradition du sénat mais sur des
textes qui engage encore une fois la
team qui engage la conscience
personnelle bien ça devrait être des
textes qui dépasse les consignes de
partir autres surprises à prévoir des
agitations à droite quelques sénateurs
affichent leur vote favorable derrière
alain milon ou encore fabienne keller
ils diront oui au texte à partir du 4
avril les discussions dureront au moins
une semaine et demie voilà il y aussi
des parlementaires de l'opposition qui
vaut certes un texte sur le mariage gay
et et même peut-être des députés ump sur
la réforme du marché du travail
en tous les cas d'accord sur l'emploi
très certainement la semaine dernière
sur ce plateau bonsoir à la vilaine ça
qu'est-ce que la discussion vous
apparaît a priori moins tendue sur le
mariage pour tous au sénat qu'à
l'assemblée nationale jean question
serait effectivement oui je pense que ce
que je viens d'entendre de l'opposition
ici c'est que il n'y aura pas cette
avalanche d'amendements répétitif et
cette idée qu'il fallait absolument
faire durer le débat le plus longtemps
possible dans des conditions peu et
quand même pas facile les nuits et des
nuits à des blanches prévu pas de week
end
gouvernement est à la disposition du
sénat s'il doit y avoir des nuits
blanches et si ça doit durer plus
longtemps ça durera plus longtemps
est ce que le texte tel qu'il est sorti
de la discussion à l'assemblée nationale
a besoin d'être corrigé selon vous
est-ce que le gouvernement va présenter
quelques amendements le gouvernement non
mais évidemment il ne m'appartient pas
dit au gouvernement ni à personne de
dire au sénat que ce texte ne serait pas
amendables le sénat va faire son travail
et nous enregistrons travail du sénat
donc a priori rapaces qu'on appelle un
vote conforme par rapport au texte voté
à l'assemblée nationale et donc une
seconde lecture sur le texte mariage
pour tous
du coup d il n'ya pas d'exigence de ce
point de vue là et le gouvernement
respectera le travail du sénat donc on
verra à partir de début avril au sénat
qu'astrid 4 avril quatre projets de
révision constitutionnelle en conseil
des ministres à partir de demain alain
vidalis c'est un peu la surprise de la
journée ces projets de loi concerne la
suppression de la cour de justice de la
république
la réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
l'inscription du dialogue social dans la
constitution ainsi que la fin du statut
de membre de droit du conseil
constitutionnel pour les anciens
présidents de la république dit moi si
je vis quelque chose alors c'est vous
avez à peu près juste un peu dans le
désordre donc je vais vous dire très
précisément le contenu des quatre textes
qui seront présentés demain au conseil
des pistes d'abord de véraison
le premier texte portera sur la réforme
du conseil supérieur de la magistrature
réforme de sa composition rfr 200 le
deuxième texte portera sur le statut
juridictionnelle du chef de l'état au
sens civil et des ministres avec la
suppression de la cour de justice de la
république c'est le même texte c'est le
second le statut pénal du chef de l'état
le statut pénal je viens d'arriver
statut juridictionnelle je vous
expliquais après la raison qui est
commune sur des textes n'ont pas été
retenus troisième texte sur le cumul des
mandats des ministres donc
l'interdiction l'exécutif local et le
conseil constitutionnel c'est à dire
l'impossibilité pour les présidents
après ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui les
anciens présidents pardon de la
république d'être membre de droit et
quatrième texte sur la démocratie
sociale
donc vous n'avez garder que les textes
qui finalement faux consensus et qui
aurait une chance d'obtenir une
majorité un homme en gris il en a
plusieurs et qui obéissent exactement ce
que vous venez de dire quelle est la
logique
la logique c'est que le premier ministre
a été chargé par le président de la
république à la suite du rapport de
lionel jospin de recevoir l'ensemble des
groupes parlementaires des responsables
de partis pour savoir comment on pouvait
espérer avoir une majorité des trois
cinquièmes sur telle ou telle réforme
il ne sert à rien sachant que la
majorité n'a pas à elles seules ces
trois cinquièmes et qui donc il faut
qu'il y ait sur chaque texte une
participation de l'opposition actuelle
pour que cette réforme ait lieu donc ça
ne sert à rien de présenter des textes
on sait par avance qu'ils n'arriveront
pas à réunir cette majorité est
d'ailleurs si la question suivante mais
elle est naturelle était de savoir
pourquoi quatre textes et pas un seul
d'abord ce n'est pas une première ça
déjà existé trois réformes par exemple
un seul congrès en 2007
select cepex ça laisse la possibilité
d'en voir peut-être deux adoptés de
rejeter non non non c'est pas ça parce
que ne pas les voir adopter tout
s'efface à d'abord ça peut exister mais
c'est surtout le fait que quand on a
fait les consultations
vous avez des gens qui sont opposés à 1
est un des quatre si vous les mettez
tous ensemble ils vont voter contre la
globalité est donc aujourd'hui à
rechercher les fics l'efficacité non non
non non l'objectif mais c'est pour ça
parce que vous avez certain qu'ils ne
voteront pas tel ou tel texte mais qui
en vaut d'autres et donc l'opinion
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on peut avoir
propre d'être une majorité peut-être
alors donc c'est un coup de poker
non c'est pas un coup de poing coups
tour de tête quand je vous dit peut-être
celle inverse celle inverse extrêmement
j'accepte pas le peut-être mais si je
vous dis c'est à coup sûr alors là vous
allez me dire quelle arrogance quelle
prétention dont la sélection de ces
textes là c'est sur la base des
conditions politiques qui nous
permettrons on l'espère d'arrivée sont
les drapés tous adoptés
on l'espère est un port tous à l'opt et
dernière question sur cette révision
constitutionnelle du coup le congrès
aura lieu quand je peux pas c'est une
prérogative du président de la
république m'a un peu
les rues calendrier parlementaire tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui probable fin
juillet peut-être peut-être en ces temps
derniers points peut-être donc en tous
les cas cette absence de majorité là je
conduis françois hollande à renoncer à
une partie de ses promesses de campagne
non mais il ne renonce à rien ses
convictions n'ont pas changé l'écran
mais l'application est bien à quoi ça
sert mais attendez c'est pas lui qui est
responsable du fait que sur telle ou
telle position
monsieur borloo ou les amis de monsieur
sarkozy ont changé de position
aujourd'hui quand vous interrogez
monsieur borloo ou les groupes
centristes dans certains avaient dire
mon bonnet sur tel ou tel texte qui
n'est pas là et je veux évoquer le droit
de mode
voilà le statut pénal où le droit de
vote des étrangers mais quand
aujourd'hui vous les recevez mais qu'il
dise au premier ministre on le votera
jamais franchement mettre cette réforme
à l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui et qu'elle
aille à un échec
c'est la meilleure façon de l'enterrer
au jour le jour bras l'a condamné pour
toujours et voilà et nous voulons pas
qu'il y ait ce n'est ni enterré le droit
de vote des étrangers non le panda non
pas nous espérons que lorsque seront pas
c'est peut-être certaines échéances ce
qui c'était ceux qui s'étaient prononcés
pour et bières seront revenu à de
meilleures intentions mais dans tous les
cas ce qu'on veut pas c'est qu'il y ait
un vote négatif qui enterrerait
définitivement ce qu'on ne peut pas
faire aujourd'hui nos convictions et
celle du président de la république et
du premier ministre reste les mains
autre promesse de campagne c'est la
limitation du cumul des mandats la le
texte vous nous aviez dit la dernière
fois qu'on vous avis sur ce plateau que
le texte arrivera en conseil des
ministres avant la fin du mois de mars
est ce que c'est toujours le cas ça
reste une possibilité
c'est en restant en reste dans ce
créneau là écoutez si c'est à 15 jours
près vous m'en voudrez peut-être paix
dans tous les cas le reste le texte
reste d'actualité
iliad il ya un problème vous le savez
puisque l'avis du conseil d'état sur ce
que souhaitait françois fr a changé à
changer un peu la donne
oui mais justement est ce que le premier
ministre que le président la république
a tranché sur l'application la
limitation du cumul des mandats ce que
ça sera 2014 2017
est-ce que
derrière l'avis du conseil d'état de
musique est le gouvernement quand il est
confronté à au conseil d'état qui dit
dans une seule chose que vous pouvez pas
faire c'est de pauvreté loi qui va
remettre en cause les mandats en cours
sinon vous avez un problème de
constitutionnalité il vaut mieux qu'il y
réfléchisse
sinon dans quelques mois lorsque le
conseil constitutionnel aurait censuré
une telle démarche nous ne recevrions
mon arme des gens mais alors franches
donc des huitièmes dès midi c'est non
mais on essaye de l'arrivée d'autres
solutions c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
il ya pas d'elle il ya pas de réponse
donc le président de la république quand
le texte passera en conseil des
ministres vous donnerai la réponse ne
laisse rien n'est arbitré aujourd'hui
c'est en tout cas un même désir à tort
de s'obstiner avec l'amour toujours une
application encore nous en débattons
nous en débattons avec lui le président
de la république a rappelé aujourd'hui
une chose importante cette réforme sera
fait pour tout les parlementaires avec
l'interdiction de cumul avec tous les
exécutifs avant la fin du canoë du
quinquennat qui reste à préciser la date
d'application pour telle ou telle chose
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à la fin du
quinquennat
conformément à son engagement tel qu'il
est écrit littéralement les cette
promesse sera tenue avec une application
peut-être plus tard non en fait à la fin
du quinquennat
dans tous les cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'en 2016 à cet égard se soit tenue
mais très bien voilà examen en ce moment
au sénat revient le texte en seconde
lecture sur la modification de scrutin
de mode de scrutin pour les élections
cantonales et municipales mais aussi les
sénatoriales la droite dénonce un
véritable trip mouillage tripatouillage
parle on est fatigués acheté le mot de
jean claude gaudin électorale c'est vrai
que ça laisse un peu dubitatif toutes
ces modifications scrutin a à peine un
an des élections
alors il ya deux choses il ya le scrutin
en lui-même est le principe du scrutin
je pense que la droite dirait si je me
trompe eux il avait promis de supprimer
le conseil général puisqu'il voulait
comme conseiller territorial dont puis
de toute façon il fallait qu'il fasse un
redécoupage
comment il aurait fait ce redécoupage
sous les fourches caudines norman de ce
qu'a dit le conseil constitutionnel
c'est à dire de respecter
le plus petit canton 20 par rapport à la
moyenne dans un département plus d'un
pour cent au moins 20% des discussions
et il aurait fallu qu'il le fasse alors
c'est vrai que lorsqu'il nous accuse de
tripatouillage
je dois dire que j'écoute avec attention
parce que je sais que j'ai affaire à des
experts mais nous essaierons de le
faisant pas de mener 0 voilà c'est pour
ça que je fais attention
et donc nous essaierons effectivement
disent qu'ils n'ont jamais modifié
autant de scrutins en même temps bah je
pense que oui c'est quand même vous
excuse oui mais il ya les élections qui
arrivent en même temps mais il ya un
pays ils ont quand même un passif est un
peu l'eau revenir à la proportionnelle à
3 pour laisser pour les sénateurs ç'a
toujours été la position ça doit pas
être une surprise qu'on l'avait déjà
fait et dès qu'ils sont à un moment
donné qu'ils sont revenus au pouvoir ils
ont fait ils ont enlevé lé inverse mais
ces deux mesures
ces mesures un retour qui vous permet
automatiquement de gagner combien 10 15
sénateurs de gauche
ah non écoutés six mois si c'était ça on
aurait fait immédiatement
c'est ce qu'il faut tout faire du prince
tamino c'est ma gauche mais pas enfin
dans tous les cas vous conviendrez que
notre objectif c'est que le sénat reste
à gauche petit et c'est seulement si les
politiques ce serait pas plus simple
d'avoir un sauna réellement d'opposer
dans l'opposition plutôt qu un sénat de
gauche qui finalement retoque des
projets de loi étaient bien la réponse
est non non la réponse est non parce que
je préfère avoir ici une majorité qui
n'est pas la majorité gouvernementale
micky et qui s'inscrit dans la majorité
présidentielle avoir un président du
sénat qui est un président du sénat de
gauche que plutôt que d'avoir ses indics
il manque deux sociétés le président du
sénat non mais je vous qui n'a même pas
pourquoi le président du sénat
manquerait d'autorité je veux dire moi
je viens régulièrement aux réunions ici
joukov que ce soient institutionnels à
la conférence des présidents que ce soit
les réunions de groupe je le vois tous
les mardis matin il est très actif à ce
qu'on appelle le petit déjeuner de la
majorité où les questions politiques
samson sont abordés donc je ne souscris
pas du tout à cette appréciation qui ont
été émises notamment par marie curie
l'état encore un des membres de votre
majorité
gouvernementale oui mais ils ont droit
ces appréciations mais j'ai le droit de
penser exactement le contraire
c'est la dernière minute de l'émission
chavez c'est de gaulle + léon blum le
monde gagnerait à voir beaucoup de
dictateurs comme hugo chavez ça ce sont
les propos de victorin lurel le ministre
d outre-mer qui indignent la droite mais
le gouvernement refuse la polémique et
donc est ce que vous vous soutenez ses
propos donc je pense que ce qu'a dit
laurent fabius cet après midi c'est ce
que dit va dire le gouvernement
très honnêtement aujourd'hui un dérapage
mais c'est pas un dérapage de la part de
la droite il a été reçu deux fois deux
fois par le président sarkozy qui a dit
il faut faire des accords donnant
donnant bon ce qui a été dit par le
président de l'adir serait beaucoup
d'autres dictateurs comme hugo chavez
alors je le fais pas d'autre commentaire
que ce qu'a fait laurent fabius sur
cette question là et la réponse est
claire je crois que ce qui a été dit
compris par référence à ce café à ce
qu'a fait j'avais ce qui a été dit par
laurent fabius qui ont pris par rapport
à vos différences que nous allons et
surtout à la solidarité vis-à-vis de ce
peuple qui va maintenant rentrer dans un
processus démocratique
on l'espère vraiment pour eux un merci
monsieur lui david et mercy mercy père
il a très vite